there's a shitload of paper towels down
here so I got I got one of the legs open
I'm not as bad as that thought how's the
crab decent that what is that an egg see
I can't open like like towards the claw
yeah usually part yeah it gets like kind
of difficult with these because the
shell so soft
yeah dude I was watching castaway and
like the scene where he had finally got
like a spear right uh-huh and he [ __ ]
stabs the crab and he picks it up and it
just like loses out like oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's just like liquid crabmeat
no a castaway that's the way survivor my
boy was out there for four years eating
crab balls man what was funny was like
what was funny was where he actually
came back after those four years and he
was that like that welcome home party or
whatever
yeah I'm it was a big-ass thing your fat
legs and you looked at it I want a pub
sub right yo so where'd you get that
crab in the Jameis Winston video
yeah seasoning the crab that's where
that's where you guys weak it looks weak
damn I forgot what it looked like
honestly it was just like you got it
straight out of the cabinet yeah that's
where Jameis stole it from Publix yeah
it was that it was the public that
Publix downtown right I think you know
I'm talking about but ya know I was
barely you know it's funny I was barely
eating those crab ladies low key yeah I
I got a I got a Publix dinner and I was
eating I was
dinner yeah yeah so I've got like
chicken tenders and like mac and cheese
and [ __ ] yeah yeah so I was eating the
dinner and then Pablo and my DJ Chuck
they was eating the crab legs but I had
only took one bite for that so for the
video for the video yeah just for the
look man this [ __ ] is messy son yeah
napkin over here that's gonna serve as
my plate Luke for your laptop just use
your nose to for the mousepad
no that's cool I'll just grab it the
crab works it's touch sensitive oil
peanuts are pretty far to the boil yeah
man I love boiled peanuts like you can't
find boiled peanuts nowhere I was like
they got him they got him in like Texas
Alabama
you know George like Louisiana anywhere
else not you're not gonna find boiled
peanuts and in [ __ ] California now
you're definitely they don't look at you
like you [ __ ] crazy man they've they
got rid of all the crock pots though at
the gas stations you can't get them
anymore you know what the virus yeah but
you can't just have like a crock pot
sitting out unattended at all hours of
the day with a dirty ass spoon next to
it for you to get I just know you know I
just now realized that you right yeah
Dan that's crazy I tried to get some of
the other day but the guy looked at me
like I was an idiot they'll have that
same clock but I won't be surprised if
like never cleaned nothing to perfection
that's what makes it so good it's been
sitting there like 10 years it's
probably that the the same set of boiled
peanuts are in there all if it's not
empty guaranteed yeah they've never
changed the water and that's what makes
it so good right like a real dark one
it's like real crusty on the outside
they've been marinating [ __ ] that's when
you know it's gonna be a good batch yeah
I used to ice there so in my old
neighborhood there was the ice cream man
but like he didn't only have like ice
cream he had like [ __ ] empanadas and
like pickled sausage like pickled eggs
in like boiled peanuts and [ __ ] so
yo if you had like five bucks you was
like a millionaire you could get an
empanada some boiled peanuts [ __ ] ice
cream some chips in a soda like all the
five had and uh for Toy Story me and
published shot a video some scenes out
there and we were and this sunflower
field it was like this big as y'all did
name it as sunflower Phil was like yeah
man that [ __ ] was beautiful like usually
they have like the Tampa Bay Lightning's
logo like if you was the like a few was
like in a helicopter some [ __ ] and you
look down at it it would like go bolts
you everything about doing a country
album I feel like it's in you
it works mom because I'm the I'm the
Dale Earnhardt oh you had that that one
country song oh that's the one yeah yeah
it's in the works man like at first I
was on some [ __ ] where you know I was I
was making I got a single paper towel I
didn't I had please thank you know this
sausage is hella good the sausage is
worse so like at first what the country
said with Toy Story it was more so like
me making fun of country music yeah like
me mocking what a country song was sound
like you know that was Toy Story but the
the new show that I've been working on
as of lately it's actually like okay
this is me taking it seriously not like
awesome like like super country but it's
big baby scumbags take yeah yeah like
you're not gonna be doing like Old Town
Road right and stuff right yeah that
just came out with like a new song he
was like like trap country or whatever
really the guy with the ski mask
rmr I don't know how to say his name
[Music]
it seems like it's like starting to work
its way more into hip-hop
yeah bone like it and not just like that
corny like honky tonk badonkadonk kind
of stuff that pop-pop is becoming a lot
more accepting you know cross cross um
you know cross collaborating with cars
collaborating with other genres man cuz
do like in the 90s that [ __ ] wasn't
flying that all no I was like Bob deep
or nothing the 90s you had to be this
super lyrical hip-hop bars biggie Tupac
wu-tang type rapper but if you if you
didn't have bars like that like you know
I'm saying you ain't [ __ ] bro but now
it's very accepting it's very like you
know you can be a rapper and like talk
about you know being influenced by
Marilyn Manson right like the you know
[ __ ] like that like you know there isn't
just the uniform look and sound anymore
it's very acceptable very acceptable one
thing that's cool about like what you do
to like I see a lot of similarities to
like just like the DIY punk scene yeah
yeah yeah because you're just like out
there doing it on your own plan
wherever will have you yeah so bro I get
a lot of dad influences just from me
just growing up with kids that you know
were parted a part of the hardcore scene
going to the skate park back with the
shows that transitions I wasn't going to
shows but I had homies that played in
bands I always go there I was at the
skate park but I wasn't going to show as
a transition I'm gonna be honest with
you know he was there I was not in the
pit at all
I will not your pet adjacent yeah I was
not in the pit but yeah like growing up
in middle school you know I'm saying
middle school high school had a lot of
homies that you know as part of hardcore
bands performed transitions you know I'm
saying all that [ __ ] and just the whole
skateboarder culture mentality or that
it really you know I'm saying it it you
know me growing up with this [ __ ] it
made me uh way ahead of the curve I felt
way ahead of the curve
don't like a lot of these rappers now
that you know a lot of these guys is
just like yeah I'm a watch like a
million YouTube videos of hardcore bands
and now I'm a [ __ ] pretend like I've
known about this [ __ ] like and now I got
a Metallica show right I feel like like
all the dudes in like like uh what's his
name Russell Westbrook yeah every every
metalic eight yeah every single like
rock band from the 90s NBA players it
should be like like I feel like there
should be like like I says like like a
fine where some of these outfits this
looks so crazy
except for LeBron and the Cavs when they
won that last Finals when they were all
wearing WWE shirts they were all wearing
like LeBron was weren't Undertaker shirt
Kevin Love was wearing a stone-cold
shirt and like the whole like the top
like four players that were all wearing
like WWE shoes that's fire LeBron be
having some fits though I know you're an
ultimate warrior shirt because I beat
the Warriors they wore the ultimate
warrior
LeBron be having some fish what do you
mean some fits oh oh okay
we're not up to dating this is a sling
that's been born in the past five years
that's down in corneas [ __ ] it kind of
made me thing like Danny this is deep
really scraping the barrel here I get
some sausage
[Laughter]